hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast increase esi-ms throughput up
to 10 times by multi-segment injections
I am Brenda Kelly chem lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
lapid's and sponsored by SIA x5x helps
to improve the world we live in by
enabling scientists and laboratory and
Alice analysts to find answers to the
complex analytical challenges they face
for more information please visit sigh
XCOM we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide linda's if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please put the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems to the green Q&A button lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker John Hudson adjunct
professor at the University of Regina in
regina saskatchewan canada and a staff
scientist which sigh x before I turn it
over to John for his presentation please
respond to the polling question which
will come up on your screen this will
help John get to know his audience
John will now begin his presentation
thank you for your answers to polling
question greetings everyone and thank
you very much for joining this webinar
this morning this webinar focuses on
increasing throughput in electrospray
ionization mass spec using a technique
called multi-segment injection now I've
been working in separation science for
quite a long time and I got interested
in capillary electrophoresis around 1993
while working as a toxicologist as a
toxicologist I was analyzing drugs and
poisons for the Royal Canadian Mounted
Police forensic system and since that
time I spent most of my time on the
integration of capillary electrophoresis
with mass spectrometry see has made the
analysis of polar drugs and their
metabolites no longer much of a
challenge to toxicologists and it's an
ideal fit with electrospray ionization
mass spec since that time C is made its
way into the demanding regulatory
environment of biopharma and Quality
Assurance quality control its use speaks
volumes about the technique and its
dedicated scientists who are using it to
deal with analytical challenges ranging
from the routine to the exotic today I'd
like to go over three sections in my
talk the first one is to discuss
conventional methods and optimizations
using standalone siiii in an attempt to
decrease analysis time and thus increase
throughput the second part I'd like to
talk about ces ims which can provide a
very effective tool in increasing
increasing analysis speed and decreasing
the total time required and then I have
a couple of case examples that I'd like
to show you using methamphetamine and
its metabolite amphetamine as an example
so what tools are available for
decreasing analysis time
that can about 10 years ago now a group
over and in Switzerland the jungle goo
phase group published a couple of papers
that I bring to your attention now these
papers were used in standalone siiii
that is not connected to mass
spectrometry to look at the various ways
that one can use capillary
electrophoresis to speed up analysis and
this was an excellent study that I'd
like to to show you now some of the
points there were five considerations
actually here to increase speed there
were simple things that we're done such
as using shorter capillary or increase
the voltage across the capillary the
field strength with that combination you
could speed up your analysis of course
that would depend on the resolution that
that existed in your separation you
could also change the pH or coat the
surface of a capillary to increase the
eof which is the intrinsic flow within
the capillary this is used also to
stabilize migration times in see where
needed another thing that you could do
was to inject from the short side of the
capillary if you had an adequate
separation of the analytes this is
commonly used in chiral standalone siiii
this is really not possible of course in
ze SI or CEMS because there is no outlet
end of the capillary again if the
separation of the analyte is adequate
you can also speed things up by applying
pressure to the inlet side of the
capillary electrophoresis instrument in
other words if the separation has been
achieved you can simply push everything
to your detector whether it be a UV
detector or ultimately a mass spec
detector multiple segments injections
can also be used in stand-alone siiii in
many applications and this slide shows a
practical example from a few years ago
when I was working at the Royal Canadian
Mounted Police lab and this application
was developed for a number
reasons the the application has shown
involves multiple injections of drugs of
abuse using internal standards in one
run and this was used to provide urgent
information required by police officers
involved in purchasing large quantities
of street drugs such as cocaine heroin
and MDMA or ecstasy it employs the use
of an internal standard which is very
important and the calculation of peak
area ratios the area ratio attic area
ratio is that of the drug of abuse to
the internal standard duplicate
injections of the standards within of
the standard of interest like heroin for
example with the internal standard were
compared to the case samples and using
that ratio we were able to quickly
calculate the percentage of drug in the
powder that would be it would have been
submitted now why is that important well
it's important because this is a safety
issue for the investigating officer if
he buys a small sample of drug and then
goes back to try to buy a larger
quantity it's very important to have
accurate information so that the
trafficker does not does not realize
that it this is a Buy and and that
information is critical to the safety of
the officer the work of and the use of
multiple injection techniques techniques
has recently resurfaced in the exciting
area of metabolomics and the work shown
in this slide was done by Philip Brits
McKibben's group in Hamilton Ontario
Canada and for those starting to apply
this technique this is a very good paper
a very good starting point I also thank
Philip for allowing me to use the slide
and the graphic that i'm going to show
next so in multiple segments injections
the samples are injected sequentially
under the capillary and they're
separated by means of a spacer and
in this case the spacer is usually an
injection of the background electrolyte
there may be some rinsing and cleaning
steps at the beginning to ensure that
the internal surface of the capillaries
uniform and allows good reproducibility
the volume of the spacer is determined
in method development for the separation
at hand separations done using an
applied voltage across the capillary
usually 25 kV up to 30 kv and I use 30
kv and you'll see that in the conditions
which I'll show later as a sort of a
proof of principle as to whether
multiple segments injections would work
at that time I was working in in some
metabolomics experiments and i did a
multi-segment injection shown here which
involved the injection of eight samples
in each run so in two runs I was able to
get a full full calibration curve and
these were single point calibrations and
also I also include it as you'll see on
the right hand side a urine sample which
was volunteer your and of course that
was my urine in order to calculate the
amount of arginine that was spiked into
synthetic urine so this was really the
spark that encouraged me to go and have
a look at further verification of this
type of technique now let's talk a
little bit first of all about the
detection and separation mechanism that
we use and I'd like to provide a little
bit of detail on the cesi which is a
very low flow high sensitivity technique
now the acronym CESI describes the
integration of cee with electrospray
ionization into a single dynamic process
within the same device now what does
that mean it means that the sprayer
itself is built into the separation
capillary
and as such it there are no connections
involved to to have to consider some
things such as dead volume or connection
problems the end of the sprayer tip is
part of the cotillion is precisely and
chemically engineered to micrometer
tolerances the other point is that the
internal diameter is 30 microns 30 micro
micrometers this is not modified as in
nano LC where most of the abilities are
pulled to a very fine point the sprayer
tip is not modified at all and this
helps to eliminate potential clogging of
the tip the electrical connection is
made between the ESI needle through with
static conductive liquid through the
wall of the capillaries which sprayer
tip to the background electrolyte inside
the capillary itself
some of the intrinsic properties of CES
I also applied to capillary
electrophoresis as well charts and polar
molecules can be analyzed without
derivative a shin this results in a lot
of labor intensive time saved the loaf
over flow rates these low flow rates are
very low they can be under 10 nano
litres per minute and as a result you're
now working in the mass sensitive region
versus the concentration sensitive
region and there is much better
sensitive sensitivity down at those low
floats along with improved ionization
and much lower electrospray voltages and
all the good things that go along with
that such as reduced iron suppression
reduced matrix effects so as those low
flows the sensitivity is almost
spectacular the sapling requirements in
cee are extremely low we're talking
about nano leader volumes injected which
corresponds to low phantograms on the
capillary and that is of course before
it gets into the mass spec difficult to
estimate how much actually gets into the
mass spec of course in order to get
those sample from those low volumes both
microliter volumes in order to sample
nano leaders from microliters it's
important to have a mechanism of vile as
you can inject from and shown here is
and is a new nano vial which is unique
to science instruments this is a low
volume vial available which allows
sampling down to a few microliters the
vials are validated to five microliters
but it is possible to get down to one
microliter depending on the sample
itself such as viscosity
a couple of other properties of cesi
it's essentially non-destructive in that
you're injecting nanometer quantities
from micro litre amounts so basically
your your factor is of the order of a
thousand you hardly is any sample at all
the separation options include the
pressure assistance at any stage in the
separation to shorten the overall fun
times and by that I mean once the
separation is done you can simply use
pressure at the inlet and I've mentioned
that before to push everything off
injection can also be done using
pressure or using voltage and this slide
I just wanted to reiterate to the to the
Cee users out there that it's important
to consider using voltage injection or
electric genetic injection in your
processes and there are many reasons for
this like I want to describe at this
point both both injection techniques on
the right hand side the hydrodynamic
detection simply means injection by
pressure of a fluid by pressure or
possibly by vacuum vacuum of course is
not possible in mass spectrometry CEMS
so you can inject using pressure and
this results in a representative sample
being introduced to the capillary and
this is similar to gas chromatography
and liquid chromatography sample
introduction however in capillary
electrophoresis and it's the ESI the
injection using voltage is also possible
and this is this differs from GC or LC
where that can't be done so a voltage
your electro kinetic injection on the
left-hand side is essentially the result
of turning on the voltage and migrating
the ions of interest on to the capillary
and this is a number of effects it is
really a built-in preconcentration
effect
and also what it does is it
discriminates between which ions you
want to get out of the capillary so for
example if you want cations to get on
you would have the mass spec as
essentially your negative electrode on
the other end and this is important
especially if one has very dirty samples
so that you can leave behind in this
case you'd leave behind acidic material
and neutral material and only migrate
cations of interest such as nitrogenous
bases which have been protonated the
approach used in msi work multi-segment
injection is that really a combination
of a pressure injection along with the
method called transient ice attack of
ERISA's I won't go into what that is
simply to say that you dissolve your
samples in a an electrolyte which allows
a very precise focusing to happen of
your of your sample analytes those
samples are reconstituted in 25 milli
molar ammonium acetate and each segment
is injected followed by the spacer the
cesi itself is very easy to set up what
be shown here is a schematic showing the
consumable cartridge arrangement where
the where the where the sprayer tip is
as shown I'm just going to draw an arrow
to the sprayer tip hope everybody can
see that the sprayer is enclosed in a
retractable tip and that's all part of
the same consumable and that sprayer tip
is then inserted into a an adapter into
the mass spec and the adapter is
specific to that particular mass spec
this slide shows the integration of the
solution and in this case the CSI
thousand-plus instrument
is interfaced with a sigh 5600 triple
top and this is of course used via a
nano nano source in this case I think
it's a nano flow 3 and that makes the
connection with the CES I as a little
break and Pradas with some more
information I was wondering whether
you'd be able to do one more polling
question for me and this is what are the
average number of samples my lab runs
per week we'll give you a couple of
seconds to do this i find this always
very interesting to find out what people
do so just give you a couple of seconds
to to check it in and I believe we're
going to quickly display the results so
we have lots of people out there doing
lots of samples per week very
encouraging thank you very much for
doing that so for my case study that I
did I selected a drug really a drug
that's very prominent in the news this
is methamphetamine which is also known
as crystal meth and you can just about
turn on the news any night and you'll
hear a result some some news describing
the effect of methamphetamine whether it
be a car crash or a shooting or whatever
so this drug is in the news and i
decided that i would take a look at it
along with its metabolite amphetamine
and in this particular case studies
samples were spiked into synthetic urine
samples the extraction protocol is quite
a simple extraction protocol which is
used widely around the world it's a
liquid-liquid extraction protocol which
can be used on either whole blood urine
serum plasma or
fluids the thing to note here is that
the protocol shown that suggests one mil
this can easily be scaled down to a few
microliters down to twenty microliters
or even will even less with no changes
to the actual protocol itself the final
sample is dissolved in a hundred
microliters so we are injecting nano
leaders from a hundred microliters and
you'll see a calculation at the end of
my talk the multi-segment injection cesi
conditions are described here the
capillary itself was a 91 centimeter
long capillary as I mentioned before
with the internal diameter 30 microns
and the other interesting part is in the
sample preparation where the samples
were dissolved in 25 milli molar
ammonium acetate peach 4.4 for this ice
attack of rhesus focusing step which
gives very sharp peaks and allows very
high resolution the samples were
pressure injected with a spacer of about
a 60 second to psi so spacer and the
background electrolyte was ten percent
acetic acid and we ran at 30 kv now a
lot of people look at the results and
say how does it actually work how does
it how does the method actually work so
what I've done here is put this very
busy slide in here along with the
graphic that I described earlier simply
to show you that the injection portion
of the methods and it can be changed
from one injection up to many injections
it shows a 2 PSI 5 second sample
introduction followed by a spacer and
this is done multiple times as per the
graphic that I described earlier and
this in this case this is an eight
sample multi-segment injection in each
run here's an example of spikes done in
urine for the quantification of
methamphetamine so the slide shows two
runs and eight sample on the left and a
sample on the right for single 10-point
calibrations for methamphetamine now in
each pane the methamphetamines on the
top and the corresponding internal
standard which in this case was a d11
deuterated internal standard for in this
case methamphetamine that's on the
bottom so the calibration is done by
doing a peak area ratio of the area of
the methamphetamine on the top to the
internal standard on the bottom and I've
also put in the order as well
calibrations for methamphetamine were
created from in this case triplicate msi
injections which of course were
sequential and gave excellent linearity
with our squared values greater than
point 995 interestingly the polynomial
or quadratic model gave values near
unity I put that on there just because I
could so the metabolite of amphetamine
also is is shown here and similarly the
calibration is calculated by using the
area of the amphetamine to the area of
the internal standard and the linearity
for the amphetamine was again very good
as well as further proof of principle I
decided I would extend this out time
permitting and in my msi further
experiments I was able to get up to 12
samples per run and I simply used as an
lod and loq the low calibrator or one
nanogram per mil spiked into urine and
each segment injection introduces about
just under two nano leaders from a total
volume of 100 microliters again this is
really non-destructive sampling and this
corresponds to about 17 temp 2 grams of
the drug on the capillary from the one
nanogram
per mil sample sample segment and this
shows the this again was triplicate
injections showing the linearity of the
amphetamine on the left and
methamphetamine on the right so my
concluding remarks are very general
using multi-segment injections the
esi-ms it's clear that we can increase
throughput significantly using the this
particular technique the quantification
of the case study analytes were all done
with input very good linearity over
three orders of magnitude if you look at
the total times involved in one run this
thing would include capillary rinses
injection of samples separation ramp
down time and movement of course of the
mecca of the sampling mechanism within
the instrument so a total of samples can
easily be analyzed in 40 minutes or
about 44 minutes per sample standard
four minutes per sample and this is
almost a 10x improvement over a run of
40 minutes which also includes all those
steps time permitting I'm continuing
work on this to optimize the method and
to further increase throughput so I'd
now like to turn this back over and like
to thank everybody first or attending
the webinar and I could turn it back
over to Brenda for a couple more
questions thank you John for that
informative presentation lots of good
information there before we have our
audience questions I would just like to
ask them once again kindly take a moment
to respond to the poll question that
will be coming up on the screen and
while they're doing that and that's
going on I'll be reminding you how to
submit questions questions can be
submitted by typing them in the green
Q&A box we found by clicking on the
green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window try to answer as many of your
questions as we can and we do have one
question right up top one of our
audience members asked what is the flow
difference John between CEMS and beep I
in and I assuming that you're referring
to when you say cems you referring to
see flow cems the comparison is is an
order of magnitude for example I did a
lot of Sheikh liquid work years ago and
we were using makeup flows and column
flows that were around around two micro
liters per minute in CES I the the flows
as I indicated in the slides where we're
down in low nano liters per minute
typically around 10 or 15 natalie is per
minute depending on the type of kapil
are used and type of separation done
awesome thank you we do actually have
another question with nano LCMS our lab
also injects from few micrometers what
is unique about your nano vials well the
nano vial has been designed to allow the
introduction of small microliter
quantities and to allow the electrode
and the capillary to be positioned
accurately in the liquid and to provide
both electro kinetic and a voltage
injection so that's quite unique also
it's been designed to to go into the
sample trays as a pair to ensure precise
alignment with the mechanism in the
instrument great we've another question
once the cow curve has been injected are
your unknown samples also run in
multi-segment or individually did you
repeat that one for me our audience
member asks once the cal curve has been
injected or
your unknown samples also run in
multi-segment or are they run
individually yes the unknown samples are
run simply as another sample and can be
inserted anywhere in the multi-segment
injection area for example you could
bracket your unknown samples with
calibrators on either side or blanks and
internal standard remember that the
spacer itself is really a blank which
will indicate whether there's any
carryover between the between samples so
that's a it's all there's a built-in
blank as well so that to reiterate the
answer to your question you can put your
your analytes anywhere at the beginning
or end and intersperse them with D
calibrators thank you for that our next
question how much sample volume is
minimally needed in the nano vial for a
reliable injection
well as de nano vial was validated down
to five microliters and to go any lower
it really depends again on the solution
that you're using the disk assa t
whether you can actually get it down and
positioned in the bottom of the nanobot
to date most of the samples most samples
are dissolved in a fairly dilute
background electrolyte and are easily
positioned with a long pipe at tip into
the bottom of the nano vile great that
is all the time we have for questions
today I do want to thank our audience
for attending and for their great input
I also want to thank John for his
presentation and our sponsor science
from making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May of 2016 new receive an email from
laggards alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you for joining us we
hope to see you next time goodbye